obviously we're in Washington but there
was lots of focus back home about brexit
a deal a draft deal has been done
there's been some difficulty getting it
through the Commons but broadly speaking
I mean are you encouraged that there is
any kind of a deal at the moment is this
good news for the economy well I suppose
that it's good that we have a deal and
let the EU and the British government
and the Irish government have agreed on
a deal it's frustrating that Parliament
can't seem to make up its mind on it and
hasn't been given a chance really to
vote but in the coming week let's hope
that they do I think most people
probably feel that this has gone on for
far too long and just have the view that
you know just do it do you see that do
you see this as being better for the UK
economy worse for the UK economy is it
possible to make that judgment well I
think it's a mistake to try and map any
particular deal into precise numbers
about whether it's good or bad for the
British economy my view has always been
that a decision to leave the European
Union in the long run is not likely to
have a major impact on the British
economy either way what it has done is
provoked a tremendous political and
constitutional crisis and in Nice if he
said in that you're slightly going
against the grain of us many other
economists and you know it's been seen
as quite controversial but I think
there's an awful lot of bogus
quantification that's gone on in trying
to justify positions held quite honestly
for other reasons including for the Bank
of England no I not say that at all I
think it's very interesting if you look
at what the bank has said they'd not
forecast what the consequences would be
what they did was to say what's the
worst that could happen
and we must make sure the financial
sector is ready for the worst that could
happen that's their job and they've done
done that extremely well I wish the rest
of government have been as enthusiastic
and energetic in beginning ready to give
the UK a choice between different
options and and and now what is what is
your hope
well it would be really nice to have to
be to be able to stop talking about it I
think everyone is completely fed up with
what's going on you can't have a
parliament that can do only one thing
which is to vote against every
conceivable alternative I've said before
we need a new Parliament and I think we
need an election where it's clear which
people believe in remain and which
people believe in leaving and whichever
parties or coalition of parties obtain a
majority in that general election will
be able to claim that they have both a
public mandate and a majority in the
House of Commons to pass the legislation
needed to pursue that objective
irrespective of whether that's remain or
leave we just have to resolve this now
and I just find it extraordinary that
Parliament cannot bring itself together
even today to have a vote on the
principle of the deal but that they have
to you know start passing lots more
amendments this is playing games in the
mind of the most most of the British
people because most people in Parliament
probably believe in remained they also
happened to vote for a referendum
Parliament's brought this on itself and
frankly the sooner we can get rid of
this the better okay I mean Kay you know
let's move on to to what you've been
talking about here in Washington because
you know that is an issue that that's
that certainly the focus on brexit in
the UK has meant that we're not looking
perhaps as much as we might normally do
at the global economy but you're like
it's worse than that I think we're not
even looking at the underlying economic
challenges for the United Kingdom we
have one of the lowest saving rates in
the British economy of any country in
the g20 safe perhaps for Argentina we're
not saving enough to finance our
pensions we're not saving enough to
finance care for the elderly we're not
saving enough to finance investment in
infrastructure and we haven't yet worked
out how we going to be able to produce
more money for the National Health
Service these are the big challenges
what do we do about the education of 50
to the population who don't go to
college or university these are the
issues that will determine our
prosperity in the future not brexit and
it's a great shame that this issue has
dragged on for so long that we've been
distracted from thinking about things
which are important even just for the
United Kingdom do it did you understand
though why people are so fixated on
their I don't understand why politicians
have allowed it to drag on for so long
no and I don't believe there's any
support amongst the public for letting
it drag on for so long we need to focus
on the real economic challenges and you
know here in Washington people have
really focused on very different
questions and so on that's you have been
looking and thinking quite a lot about
the state of the global economy and you
know how would you assess where we are
right now so I think the world economy
is in a low-growth trap as I've
described it we've we have some growth
but it's not enough to get to where we
should be or where we thought we would
be just before the financial crisis hit
that means that we could be even worse
off than we were after the Great
Depression relative to our expectations
so this was what the the financial
crisis in the aftermath worse than the
Great Depression
well not in terms of what's happened to
unemployment no but the economy has
grown more slowly for a longer period
than it did for the twenty years after
the Great Depression now we've got a bit
of time left but unless we grow pretty
rapidly over the next you know six or
seven years we will find ourselves in a
position where will we be behind where
we were after the Great Depression and
that's a pretty dispiriting outcome are
we heading for another financial crisis
well the honest answer is no one knows
but it's quite sobering to realize that
the amount of debt in the world economy
even relative to GDP is higher today
than it was at the beginning of 2007
it's higher now yes and people said how
do we get into this crisis too much
borrowing too much spending but when our
in a position where we've got even more
borrowing and not enough spending so the
idea that borrowing is going to be the
way to
generate growth in the world economy
doesn't seem to me terribly compelling
so how worried are you well I'm not
worried that we're gonna have a great
collapse in the next 12 months but the
point is that we ought to be having
aspirations to get GDP back to where we
thought it would have been if we'd sat
having this discussion in 2005 and said
where do we think GDP will be 20 years
from now 2025 actually the path were on
is going to be well below where we would
have expected in 2005 that we would be
able to reach just based on an
extrapolation of past trends and that
was a reasonable expectation now we will
require quite dramatically rapid growth
which i think is not feasible to get to
that point so we really ought to be
thinking how can we restore growth in
the world economy so that we don't have
to rely on too much borrowing from
overseas and we save more as a country
these are deeper questions which affect
everyone I mean everyone believes that
we need more money for the National
Health Service and we need to provide
pensions and we need to provide care for
the elderly but the question is how we
pay for it and we haven't actually
worked this out do you what are the what
are the kind of lessons from having
actually fought a financial crisis for
those who might well have to fight one
in the future it's a greater cooperation
is crucial and I think that in terms of
dealing with financial crises we are not
yet well placed to ensure that if there
were a big crisis and the Bank of
England had to create lots of money in
order to meet a demand for liquidity
could we do it in a way that would mean
that we can explain to people and
explain to Parliament that we had a
framework for doing it that was
consistent with the concerns that people
might have about bailing out banks I
think we've got have a much more
intensive debate about an explicit
design of a firefighting facility that
Parliament approves ex-ante and the
central bank then delivers in the middle
of the crisis is it depressing to you
that you know you've been banging on
about this for ages we
still facing the same problems I have
one financial crisis later do you
sometimes wonder what it would take for
the different countries around the world
to actually come together to sort this
out it is depressing but I think the one
problems are bad enough even politicians
have to wake up and deal with it and I
think that a although we're not facing
you know high unemployment a decade or
more very slow growth which is kind of
what we're facing what we're facing the
great stagnation it's what is gradually
feeding in to political concern that
they can't achieve their own objectives
because the money isn't there without
faster growth and I think that just
relying on central banks to sort of be
active in cutting rates any further
people are beginning to realize now that
this can't possibly be the answer deep
down we are in a world of extraordinary
uncertainty about economic policy
whether it's trade whether what's going
to happen in a tan America population
explosion in Africa the monetary union
in Europe all of these things there's
more uncertainty today than ever before
and these things affect investment right
across the world
and also in the UK and so that that the
outlook sounds a bit scary
well one shouldn't exaggerate all this I
think there are there are a structural
problems we've had low growth for a
decade I don't want us to have that for
another decade that isn't the same we're
facing a crisis next week we're not but
unless we recognize the nature of the
problem of the low growth trap which is
that it's not something that's amenable
just to another cut in interest rates
people have to accept that politicians
need to accept that
all the things that they are responsible
for play into this they can't just pass
it on to the central bank and say oh
just cut rates and we'll get growth
again it hasn't worked for ten years and
it it won't work it was right to cut
rates but it's not enough where we are
we need a much wider set of policies to
get out of this